tras volver de Teherán Rafael grossi
tiene cara de felicidad por una buena
razón Irán ha aceptado volver a conectar
las cámaras de vigilancia de varios
emplazamientos nucleares y aumentar el
ritmo de las inspecciones
los últimos meses ha habido una
reducción en algunas de las actividades
de vigilancia vigilancia adicional y
otras actividades en el área de
verificación que teníamos vinculadas a
las cámaras vinculadas a los mecanismos
de refuerzo en línea en términos de los
sistemas de monitoreo de flujo que no
estaban en operación por lo que hemos
llegado a un acuerdo para que vuelvan a
operar
operatings
will be operating Again el organismo
Internacional de la energía atómica
había detectado recientemente partículas
de uranio enriquecido a más del 83%,
Mientras que el 90% es necesario para
fabricar una bomba atómica Rafael grossi
llegó viernes y se reunió con varios
responsables iraníes entre ellos el
presidente ebrahim Racing el objetivo
era relanzar las negociaciones
estancadas
Hemos llegado a un acuerdo para definir
nuestra cooperación Y obtener garantías
como parte del histórico acuerdo de 2015
Irán limitó su enriquecimiento de uranio
al 20%. Esta visita Teherán es un primer
paso para reactivar el acuerdo que se
vino abajo en 2018 tras La retirada de
Estados Unidos en la presidencia de
Donald Trump